رب الوثائق السريه اذا تشتعل بين الرئيس
الامريكي الحليج وبايدر والرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب وايضا الذي طالما ادانا
ترامب بسبب تستره على وثائق سريه بمكان
اقامته بفلوريدا وجد نفسه في موقف مشابه
بعد الكشف عن وثائق السريه كانت في حوزته
الموضوع لم يتوقف عند هذا الحد حيث كشف
البيت الابيض عن اكتشاف الدفعه الثانيه من
الوثائق السريه كان يحتفظ بها بيض في
منزله بمقاطعته بولايه دلور هذه هي الدفعه
الثانيه تم العثور عليها تحديدا في منطقه
التخزين في مراه في منزل
مع وجود وثيقه واحده في غرفه مجاوره واعلن
مستشاره بايضا عن قيامهم بتبليغ وزاره
العدل مباشره بعد العثور على الوثائق وان
محامي الوزاره احتفظ بها بالوثائق وتاتي
هذه الدفعه الثانيه بعد الاولى التي تم
العثور عليها في مكتب مركز ابحاث تابع في
واشنطن العاصمه وضمت 10 وثائق ووصفت
بالسريه وترجع الو سريه التي عثر عليها في
مكتب بايرن للفتره بين 2013 و2016
وتاتي هذه القضيه في وقت يواجه فيه الرئيس
الديمقراطي تحديات من جانب الجمهوريين
الذين انتزعوا الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
خلال الانتخابات النصفيه كما ان القضيه قد
تخدم مصالح ترامب في ملف الوثائق السريه
التي عثر عليها في مقر اقامته في مارغو
وبهذا الخصوص كتبت صحيفه نيو نيويورك
تايمز ان اكتشاف الوثائق يطرح تساؤلات حول
بيض الذي كان يفخر بالالتزام بالقواعد
التي انتهاكها ترامب فالعثور على وثائق
السريه في مكاتب تعود لبيضن يمكن ان يؤثر
على فرصه توجيه اتهام جنائي لدونالد ترامب
كما قد يدعم الحادث ادعاءات ترامب بتعرضه
للاستهداف لعرقله ترشحه لسباق البيت
الابيض في 2000 و 2020 وهو ما يفسر تحركات
ترامب الذين طالبه بتعيين مستشار الخاص
بالتعامل مع ضجه وثائقي